hello okay hello everyone
uh let's see we seem to not have this
working properly just one second here
um
all right well
okay well welcome everyone to a welcome
language design
review this is part of our incremental
language development
series and we have a variety of topics
today
uh
and let's see first one here temperature
differences
a pretty uh specific point but since
we're going to be reviewing these
changes
um soon we wanted to discuss something
that we didn't get into a lot of detail
the last time we talked about some of
the updates for temperature differences
which is the proposed updated type
setting to differentiate
absolute temperatures and relative
temperatures I thought this was cool I
mean yeah
yeah I think the main point we had is
that we wanted to make sure you were
aware this is a
this is not standard notation I mean
there is not standard notation for
differentiating between the two of them
um Michael and Eric are pretty happy
with it Jose and I are also reasonably
happy with it but uh since we talked
about it really briefly last time I
wanted to make sure you were well I mean
I think
when will people see this
if I say one temperature minus another
they'll see this this version of
temperature right yep
is Michael here
yep you should be yep
is there any comparable notation in the
literature no
typically detect space out that one has
to differentiate between absolute and
relative but I'm not aware that anybody
uses different notational versions that
there is with a trailing degree sign
instead of a leading degree sign that
everybody hates that and that's obscure
yeah
and anything
that looks like some kind of uh you know
it's going to look like a person if we
move the Delta closer to the circle
right yeah
and we tried it with you know the the
Delta to being left or right of the
degree and it makes the type setting a
little longer yeah
well let's do it
invent invent the notation looks good
looks good to me
okay
yeah
um
will this show up what will we do in
traditional form well we also show this
in traditional form
as opposed to sort of stripping it and
just going with the traditional
ambiguous notation
uh we hadn't planned on having a
difference between them
um Michael any thoughts on that
I think we should be using it for both
yeah all right fine all right
okay let's introduce it
good stuff
see
okay position largest
so Danny has basically implemented what
we had previously discussed
um I have a futurized ref page
um that basically breaks this down but
there was still some discussion about
what we want to do with the second
argument right now it is a rank
specification
I I really don't think that should
change because otherwise it becomes a
trivial function
it doesn't add anything new
why does it say the N largest values
here because the positions of the
largest values but it's all in one
because it's its end values not n
elements
that's the whole point of the rank
and values yeah yeah yeah okay
that's the yeah the positions
by the way is this runnable in in the um
prototypes it's on the product yeah
but when it okay so so
in the single version
it's just returning a single list a
Singleton list right yes by default yes
but in the in the case where there's a
second argument even if the second
argument is a one it's returning a list
of lists correct correct
okay
do we have good precedence for that type
of behavior
offhand I don't know
anybody
by Ty
hmm
I mean you understand what I'm asking
where we return yeah
okay
let's see where the default
what version of the second argument
would give the one argument Behavior
um there might
I I don't remember if I kept this or not
there might be an automatic
I don't well that will be good I think
well try and see what it does
we're lucky it won't take that as an
order function
okay that did not
that's enough he
right and if we give it one then we'll
get a list of lists
mm-hmm one would assume oh oh I'm sorry
yeah this is the automatic is still
there doing what you expect okay
yeah
okay okay
the ordering function
we have that I did not Implement
excluded forms although I think that
would not be too hard
what is excluded forms here so take
largest and take smallest have excluded
forms because they're doing numeric
comparisons if you want to exclude
elements from the comparisons without
error messages that's what the excluded
forms does oh wow
okay that sounds nice
all right anything else we have to
figure out about this function because
it looks pretty reasonable to me um well
a is it going into 13 to B do you want
excluded forms and if so how soon
I don't think we care about excluded
forms as urgent
okay so that something could be added at
some point I think so okay
so if we are to go forward with this for
13 too then
um you know Nick is showing the page
that we worked on there's three others
that that need I need to go over
you mean position smallest and things
and the and the buy variants yes
okay position largest by
uh
yes I see that makes sense
yeah these are going to be useful
functions we should make sure they're
properly cross-linked yeah looks good to
me okay we'll get the documentation
polished up on them so that they're
ready for final review but sounds good
all right
previous time so this was something I
think that came up in a a different
meeting where you were looking at an
easy way to generate an interval from
now to some time period in the past or
some time period of the future
um and you'd propose this previous time
function that would generate it
what I just think I'm not passionate
about that form do you have a better
idea well what I was thinking is we had
just made a similar Syntax for random
date and random time where you could
give it a quantity and it would be that
quantity relative to now
and so we could potentially have the
same thing in date interval where you
give date interval a quantity and that
means from now until now plus that
quantity which might be positive or
negative I think that's a good idea
so I mean the typical thing will be you
know add temperature data of date
interval blah yeah I want the past two
months of temperature data or
um the form I'm not quite as sure about
is this pair of quantities form which
would be you know now plus the first
quantity to now plus the second quantity
so yeah I mean I don't actually
understand why add temperature data
doesn't just if you give it quantity
minus four weeks why doesn't it just do
the obvious thing
without explicitly requiring the date
interval there that seems like a useful
courtesy
yeah we could think about that uh Jose
and I started talking about this a
little bit as a notion of using quantity
as a relative date so if you provide
quantity in an argument that's typically
expecting a date do we have a universal
interpretation that works for that that
says I think we should I think we should
think of that because I think it's a
good idea
yeah I don't think the obvious thing for
air temperature data of minus quantity
would be an interval I would think would
be a moment
uh
that point right and then if we have
this convenience of you can just say
date interval of that quantity
yeah I like that I like that it's a good
idea
um
I mean I would even argue that
maybe we should support things like date
interval
of quotes year
is equivalent to date interval of
quantity minus one year
maybe so the alternate interpretation
for that would be date interval of
current date year
that would give you the current year
versus a year ago until now yeah all
right okay you're right it's I'm wrong
about what it should be yeah
but I think that we might as well use
that syntax with something
and the thing you're proposing seems
more sensible
uh but look I think this is clearly a
win date interval of a quantity positive
or negative now this thing here um
I don't like it
this thing here yeah I'm not too sure
about it either
so let's drop it yeah let's just do the
date interval of a single quantity we
understand what it means
and and quantity has a canonical form
with the with the uh minus sign inside
the number is that correct
for everything other than the
temperatures yes
okay
so for time periods that would be
standard yeah
okay all right okay
all right onward you know I I have a
certain urge to look at that low-hanging
fruit thing yeah we can jump over there
these were two things that are are
somewhat related to position largest but
they're not active development things so
okay let's go to the low hanging
things so for people who are
uh
what's in live stream this is a funny
thing this was a this was the thing
created in the early 2010s
these so-called low-hanging fruit
collection of things we could quotes
easily do so they were low hanging fruit
but the the uh uh the orchard got pretty
big but the good news is we managed to
uh you know we have managed to do a lot
of the things that were in the orchard
but now we're coming back to look at low
hanging things that haven't been done
um
okay this Cloud symbol still a thing or
did that really get
subsumed by the modern Cloud expression
form
well there's nobody here know
I think it's still a thing
um I think it was not a particularly
successful thing yeah that's right right
this is
sorry something on the back end yes I
mean it's all been the new Cloud
expression is much better
and I don't know this is a question for
as you say John Pacey
this is a whole can of worms I don't
know what that that um
domain mappings
okay this is you're right this is all
for the cloud team this is something
that was supposed to get done
which was uh kind of
um vanity Cloud URLs
it never got done
anyway the team that was supposed to do
it kind of messed up
uh
I still think it's worth doing I don't
know how difficult it is that will be a
Jason King type question
his team okay Oscar's team basically
yeah Avery and I are in the process of
starting to follow up on some of these
but we can I would ask that I mean it's
it's a question of setting up a records
and you know doing transfers of domain
uh authentication information Etc et
cetera Etc
okay but you understand what this is
doing right
there's a saying hmm when you go to that
you go to that domain
it's tied to this object right exactly
okay okay
all right let's dig in here
and there's no concert order here so no
I understand this is a concept of
should nest
have the possibility of a variable name
should it be the case it's kind of like
a nest indexed here
[Music]
and the reason one doesn't typically
care is you just use fold
well wouldn't this be superseded by in
by supplied and such things
oh it certainly would yeah it's a good
point
yes it certainly would
good point all right so that's what
happens to that one all right
map thread at a negative level
no opinion
anybody
um this is something that can be done
it's just
okay so we agreed to this at some point
there are certainly a few tickets
related to map thread I'm not sure if we
have a ticket specifically about
this so what what I remember is that
when we discussed this we ended up
saying there are three different disc
directions in which we could extend map
threat and I think it's it's the
interaction between those three things
that that becomes tricky
this by itself could be done
okay I mean is there a desperate you
know to me the story of map thread is
ultimately the story of string diagrams
and you know General tensor notation and
so on
and I don't really see the point of
making map throughout itself I mean map
there itself already you know has the
complexity level that it has and I think
we should you know insofar as we want to
have General tensor knitting we should
you do it a different way rather than
adding you know tentacles to map thread
in my opinion
yes I I see your point so this is indeed
a particular case of contractions of
level contractions in our race and and
we could have a a powerful function that
does all that can be done
that's what we should do but sort of
more of a string diagramming type thing
you know that basically defines the way
in which yeah so I mean that's a
function we should be talking about but
I think that's in the future I don't
know what's happened to the Future
arrays uh meeting series what has
happened to that
uh there is still progress I know Rob's
still working on that but um
just that we have not very frequent
patents
okay sounds like we should push for
another one sometime soon to know the
status of that and this should be in
there
okay line based syntax errors in get
huh
well that seems topical to what we've
been talking about recently with the
abstract syntax Tree Business and so on
by the way given how broad the set of
issues are that we're coming up with
here who is who was optional for this
meeting who maybe should be here if
we're really going to go through these
I think Christopher is probably the
first person I would think of well why
doesn't somebody reach out to us Bob
here too
and Nick maybe mertzen yeah I can reach
out to him yeah could you
um
okay
so this particular one here right
now when get
finds the syntax error
in a file can somebody speak to this
does anybody know how this works
no internally no probably no no no no I
mean functionally to the user it just
says syntax error right and I think it
says it online blah right it usually
tries to include a line number
okay so this says that allow the file to
be opened at that line number so this is
now a mechanism that we do have because
we do not have buttons and messages
which we didn't have seven years ago
right that would allow you to do us a of
some kind of file open on that line at
that line number yeah we can do that now
so why don't we do this it seems like an
obvious thing to do
right I don't know where the file right
and like for the you know that help uh
suggestions in the packet repository
definition notebook do exactly this
not so much on errors but on like code
parse suggestions okay fine so then
let's do it I mean it seems like an
obvious convenience
but I don't even know whether we have a
way a function that opens a file at a
particular line number
do you understand what I'm saying I mean
if I say system open I'm opening a file
right I can open up some file we'll
probably notebook open right
for this case
no the guess is reading.wl files right
but I mean you want to open them in the
current session right yeah I mean if you
if you do system open then it'll be
whatever random Association for me it
would be my IDE if I did okay and it
would be this current Mathematica if I
do notebook open
okay
so I mean what do you have in mind that
it opens in the package editor for
example exactly yes in the package
editor well that's fine then we need a
way of opening the thing at that line
number in the package editor yes
okay
so that's what which we should at least
in principle be able to do now since we
now actually have line numbers in the
package editor right we didn't even
really have that before
um mine so then it's a question of
specifying that in the notebook open
right is it an option is it a new second
argument yeah yeah either one could work
and right authentication yes needs to
opine on that so that's something for
uh I guess it's probably Avery to go
chase that
yeah I got it
okay next up
range in two
transform an interval of n elements
don't we have this now isn't that
subdivide
I think it is
looks like it to me
I mean
that's a very bizarre result
that's really bizarre it's kind of
exotic
okay bizarre it's exactly correct
explain it to me
right it's giving you men Plus Men minus
Max over three plus Max minus Min over
three
yeah oh I didn't see the plus signs I'm
being stupid here I I'm this makes
perfect sense it's all good
yeah it's nice okay so that one is done
this one here okay
okay
furthest as opposed to nearest
does it make sense
that is far from low hanging we have no
way to do it efficiently unlike nearest
it's like graph antipode
which I believe we do now have don't we
it's certainly in the function
Repository
it's in the function repository but I
don't doesn't look like we have it
um
yeah I mean there it is
um I mean nearest takes so many things
like text where furthest would be
identified
well wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute
you're saying I mean look whenever
there's a distance metric
there's the thing closest to the thing
you're asking for in the space and
there's the thing that is furthest from
what you're asking for in the space well
if the space is unbounded in every
direction well I mean but but
assuming you have objects in the space
you can ask for the furthest
string
yeah oh
if you're spay no well nearest takes a
set of objects yeah so it's finite set
so so yeah
um the problem is that on in contrast to
nearest there's no efficient way to do a
furthest
that isn't self-evident to me but but
you you are you sure of that yeah
all right to me this seems like okay I'm
gonna can we get this added let's add
this to the student project list
uh well I can I can add this
um
this is a good thing for somebody to
explore to just see whether we can make
a reasonable version of this
um
um
okay that's what that's what's happening
to that
okay Association thread
um
ghost how noises
that was my ghost yeah okay well okay
fine good the
um
Association threat don't we have this
now
we well I think it's about specifically
about adding a level spec which I don't
know if that makes any sense and there's
one usage of Association thread that I
think doesn't make any sense
um give me one usage that already exists
yes
that's uh
it can be a rule or it can be two
arguments you don't like the rule I
guess
um
I think
trying to reconstruct it uh right since
I never use it uh but uh
um
is it
[Music]
um
well I think this is let's just let's
just you know the cleavage tree here I
think this this looks fine I don't think
we should worry about level specs here
um
anyway Stumpy comments on a live stream
uh
what if the file is on this is related
to the syntax errors question what if
the file is unusually large during the
import opening large file automatically
might hang the system
um
it's a reasonable question but by the
time you've got so I mean the the
thought would be there's a syntax error
on line 17 but the file as a whole is
200 000 lines long what do we do
I mean the message could tell the user
that it's 200 000 lines long and then
they can choose not to push the button
yeah I think it's the right answer
so it's important that it's say line two
of 200 000 or something
seems like a decent Safeguard to me
uh okay let's go on here
Traverse load I think we finally have
that right now
oh look at this well guess what do we
have any in here I don't know if we have
in here but yeah we have a bunch of
these
uh
what is this
anybody ever look at this
oh my gosh 2005.
you know we're in a long-term business
that's that's the good news about this
oh my gosh
have you looked at this
no I I haven't seen this but we did four
tree traversal order do this comparison
with like a graphic order and canonical
order
what is this there's basically eight
values in your your audio is
exceptionally loud
um
is this better somewhat yeah okay
I was saying there's eight there's eight
values of tree traversal order that
correspond to
variants of canonical order and likes a
graphic order okay but pre-order and
post order is that something that we
have a concept of here
yeah that's top down versus bottom up do
we use that term do we have those
keywords
yeah you can use pre-order as a synonym
for time
yep
prove it
pretty crazy search results that don't
you think please report that Avery
that's for you please report that to the
search team
yep I got it
great
okay
so
now this comment about
uh replace
um
uh let's see does that make any sense
did you understand what I'm asking
right that replaces I think about
traversal order and that you could
potentially flip it
yeah
but now what wait what difference does
it make I mean extract
I don't think that I don't think it
really makes any difference maybe it
does
um so obviously it'll only make a
difference if you
um you know are replacing at multiple
levels otherwise I mean unless you have
some side effect right how can it affect
anything
I would think that's correct yeah I mean
or unless perhaps affects the order in
which it returns
I mean yeah if you have a pattern
no I mean extract just has part numbers
okay makes sense for functions that have
a level spec
but generally functions at position
specs the order is determined yeah okay
fine but the level spec your point is
you could replace and you could the
thing the whole tree could have barely
been replaced before you say go and make
find the sub tree and replace that
and that's determined by the traversal
order
right
am I making sense that is an issue that
I'm not sure how to resolve that we
haven't had to tackle that for trees
I'm sorry what what have we not what are
you saying oh you're saying during the
traversal you like replace parts of the
tree so depending on one order you're
doing it in you might lose things so
you're saying you did have to address
that in trees or you didn't have not
addressed that injuries
we don't have that kind of replacing
functionality yet
so it is going to come up
I mean yes
slash dot could have exactly a traversal
order
right
slot has a definite you know it can
decide map could have a traversal order
as well I mean map has right now has a
default traversal order but it could
have a specified traversal or could it
not
it could but I don't think it would do
much since map doesn't use the evaluator
the scan certainly could have a Traverse
order
you know
um well map it certainly matters what
look if you have a side effect if you
have an echo it certainly matters what
what order uh map no map just puts the
expression like it just wraps
sub-expressions and then the whole
expression evaluates
ah okay
okay it doesn't matter what order
you are mapping over it right depending
on what
it's like what are you mapping inside of
an expression or
outside
if you map inside first and then you map
in outside it's a different thing
what do you do it in the different order
no no it's not because the whole thing
will be replaced
and then it'll be returned to the
evaluator and then it will evaluate so
unless you have
so I yeah I mean it just won't matter
right you'll you'll because of the
particular implementation of map
yes right except for side effects
now even though it doesn't matter for
side effects that's what you're saying
you're saying that what actually is
happening is the whole expression is
getting created F of f of whatever it is
and then if Alice called on the whole
thing
well right it's just it's actually it's
just returned and then the evaluator
sees the expression changed and you know
reevaluates it but now now if we add
that immediate evaluate wrapper into map
like some way to force map to
immediately evaluate then then it might
make a difference yeah
okay
boy I hadn't realized we had this in
here this is kind of
um
I'm I'm going to actually I need to save
this
uh so we I didn't remember that we were
thinking about these things at that time
um but apparently we were
I got to save this in my place because
I'm about to write about all of this
um
multi-computational language design etc
etc et cetera it's kind of interesting
when we were doing this back in 2005
okay
uh all right but I think for our
purposes here
a traversal order option for these other
functions is something clearly in the
future
uh and I don't know exactly where that
goes but that's um uh so that this is an
active thing basically
that makes sense to people
yep yeah he's still only
it's like is it only the matter of
certain positions basically if you have
a list of positions where we just
extracted from expression to map over it
yeah you just no it is not so eight out
of the 12 values of tree Traverse order
can be obtained by sorting positions but
leaves firsts and its variants cannot
that's the one based on negative levels
you can't determine negative levels from
position specs
oh okay
what if you normalize it at least if you
first positions and then you just turn
it into a positive then you can sort it
at least yes but you can't use the
criteria that involve depth to the
distance to the the bottom of the tree
is not a sortable thing because you
could you could as well State look the
basic point is there's a set of
identities between part number 173 is
also part minus one minus eight
four or something right every part has
both a positive and negative
coordinatization
and some of these sortings are based on
the positive coordination sum based on
the negative is that is that a correct
characterization no it's not about
positive or negative part specs it's
positive or negative level specs
so the point is like leaves first
atoms and there's just no way from a
position spec to know how deep you know
position one two three okay I understand
I understand so your point is that
what's really at issue is not the values
in the list that represents the position
it's the position
in the position list so to speak
right yeah it's but it's basically the
issue that the you know positive depth
is defined sort of independently of
anything else whereas negative depth you
need to know the whole expression yeah
okay yeah it depends on the structure of
the tree yeah nope okay I agree all
right let's um let's keep going here
password strength estimate I thought we
had a wfr for this
wow we really don't have a a thing that
tests the strength of a password I
thought we had a such a function to move
from alpha for example
seems like a reasonable wfr function
minor can we suggest that as wfr
function yeah I think we have one that
generates strong passwords but not a
test yeah yeah
oh yeah there it is
okay all right
genealogy functions
uh
so this is obviously closely related to
trees but
I know there's been some discussion of
how
if there are things that are
specifically related to genealogy that
either need to be a separate feature
area of trees or
if there's extra extensions we need this
I don't really understand I mean the
problem with humans is that they have
two parents so to speak whereas things
in trees I don't know if it's a problem
with humans but you know trees there's
one parent
so the full story of like doing
computational genealogy would require
Dags
right like you're saying you have your
parents but some of the genealogical
terminology is is being designed in the
trees project like there's this
idea of extending physician specs with
things like uncles and parents
and and we
have been working on a design for that
okay but I mean the the dag based
genealogy
presumably there is a generalized
version of that I mean you know
our part of the tree of life happens to
have two parents per organism so to
speak
um but you know one can imagine all
kinds of other different
similar I mean in a sense it's almost
like some kind of tournament type thing
of you know from
I don't know what or a token event graph
in our modern terms
um and I guess I wonder
is there a framework that we should be
having that is sort of generalized
genealogy
and if so what would it look like and is
it just a dag framework
any comments from people
anybody
I know there's
like some things in Wolfram Alpha
yes they definitely are
well so this is unresolved
then I think we need to be talking about
dags at some point soon which might come
about in the multi-computation stuff as
well
okay so this one is unresolved so please
leave this yep unresolved
[Music]
modular equivalent Q by the way that
raises this question about whether there
should be an operator form of mod
like this
does not seem obviously crazy to me
seems useful to me
yeah it's it's you know it's something
that you brought up in LCC and we'll
discuss there okay fine it's probably
not on today's agenda but okay all right
it's not far away but what is modular
equivalent q and is it relevant
uh it's basically a predicate that you
can say you know what the result of
modulo operation should be and you get
true false
I don't know how useful it would be so
it's f a function or is it like a number
I would think that was a number yeah it
should be number in a function
right so basically so it basically saves
you the
equal equal but it saves you the mod of
X comma two
equal equal mod of Y comma 2.
I mean it is more elegant because it's
kind of like to say
is it
you know the most common form would then
be I mean I don't think this is
obviously stupid
and if we had mod equal
I don't know we don't do we have
operated forms of Q functions
yes like you
um oh yeah that's a good point yeah
match Q
I mean I don't think this would be
stupid
should it be an equal buy and then we
use the mod to a second argument or
something like that
as a more General function than mod
equal just equal by
what about the modules you're making the
argument for the mod operator then
yeah yeah
but I don't think this is particularly
good because this the the is there a
varrod's form of this I mean it's a very
strange piece of airoxism
yeah I was thinking having a list in the
first tournament
not a huge fan given that equal is not
list based
uh
it's kind of like all true
um I suppose it could be a it could be a
pure operator form
which could be equal buy right I suppose
mod equal as well but
um equal by right so equal by of the mod
of three of x y z w
ow I don't like having that be a pure
operator form I don't think anybody know
that why not all same that works like
all true
but
it just checks that they're the same
well that's exactly what same queue does
it have an operator though it's
fireworks without an operator right
all true has an operator form which is
by saying the most useful form for me
um same as as a operator form yeah oh
okay same Cube and all we did same as
instead I see
and same as as far args for
well all same bye
go ahead
I went well I was thinking that we
didn't document the varark's form of
same as but maybe I'm wrong
uh
because there was there is okay so yep
we did do it okay
but look I agree that between having mod
2 as a operator form
and
I mean all same bite does seem somewhat
useful to me
how else would you do that so this is a
list
and then the uh the operator the
comparison
which will be analogous to all true
right
I kind of like it I like it
all right let's consider this one okay
okay yep
okay and and that let's also please uh
says mod 2 is going to come up in an
hour LCC discussion right yep
okay let's keep going
methods used
so the notion here is like timing or
it's of a positive generator yep
which would take
some kind of
thing being thrown into a bucket you
know functions would throw into a bucket
information about the methods they're
using and this would then collect that
bucket
now do we think there's any like let's
take machine learning as an example
is there anything I mean the problem is
describing the methods used is like
giving a proof
you know it has its own sub language to
be able to do it
and it seems tough to do the only thing
I could imagine is that it gives the
method strings
is that realistic
yeah I mean I think it you know I don't
know that much about the the machine
learning methods but you know some of
the methods are parameterized and how
you report those
might be well that's a question whether
I mean this is okay there's a question
for the algorithmic algorithms team is
to ask them about this and to ask them
could they return what you would type
you know in other words it found a
method method are automatic but it is
like the analog of you know plot range
are automatic and you say you know
absolute options of blah right
right and it tells you what it actually
used
so the question is is there an analogous
thing here
does that make sense
yeah yeah I think we could certainly ask
around and let's let's ask about that
okay so this remains active here
so how deep this would borrow okay what
happens if we use find root very
internally
who knows
good question look the borrowing
question relates also to timing which
does not really have good you know
Rabbit Hole control so to speak that is
if a function calls some
I mean timing you know back in the day
35 years ago timing seemed like a
well-defined concept but it is far from
that because of multiple threads because
of multiple processes because of
multiple Library calls etc etc I don't
think we really even know anymore what
exactly it does do we
certainly not in all cases
I'm with parallelism and so on it's yeah
I I think it attempts to count
different threads to add add them I'm
not sure though that when we go into
libraries that all of that is counted or
I might even depend on which Library
yeah sure
and it's a question also for the new
compiler linking stuff the dynamic
Library loads stuff I have no idea
whether it it inserts timing counters
and things that's a question to ask
could the compiler groups I think
specifically Christopher
okay methods used could be a head
wrapper and then the burrowing is clear
the depth
I see what you're saying yes
that's a little weird but everything
it's a little weird no matter what
right
okay
okay
uh
anyway it's it's part of the um I I mean
I consider this
um long term it's interesting
I don't know how realistic it is
and it might also be that that
yeah I mean a thing that would be
potentially look I mean here's a couple
of problems there's both sort of time
and space problems I mean there's
there's
you get the result out
and it says okay this used you know
random forests with these parameters
great that means if I want to redo the
same computation with the exact same
you know I I can save it's the time that
it's spent to determine that you use
random forest with these parameters I
can just directly tell it the method but
what if in a version three versions on
the new defaults for some thing that
wasn't mentioned in the method
description has changed
so I'm saying because the method
description is never going to be
complete
it's always going to have some default
assumptions which might change
I think there'll be a lot of issues like
that there's also functions like and
minimum and minimum which can use
multiple methods in different steps
and again subject to change There's
issues with maybe time constraining some
methods that's going to vary based on
machine it's not it's not a clean a
cleanly
answerable sort of you know or
well-defined problem that said maybe
some of these you know it might be
useful just to give method information
even though you can't necessarily use it
for replicability
right
right okay I still think it'll be
difficult even to give that info for a
function like uh and minimize
right
yeah I kind of agree with you but I I
think it's worth exploring but
so that survives on the list clean data
set
oh yeah
huh
that's a good wfr thing to do
you know defining rules for outliers Etc
et cetera et cetera so that that means
you've got a data set and you know that
minus 999 means missing and things like
this
well I don't even know whether that's no
I mean this is more like anomaly
detection this is can we use our anomaly
detector automatically on a data set
which I don't think we properly
investigated and that maybe should go to
the machine learning team
does that make sense
yeah we can certainly floated by them
we're just tell an issue I'm just
telling this to you my
uh newest friend James Kirk Maxwell uh
um in well from alpha somehow
somehow uh
the distinguished Mr Maxwell had starred
in a movie from 1964 according to uh
some brief moment of of Orphan Alpha
okay horrible a horrible outlier in some
you know just some I think it was
something that came out of some
thing where we thought we were getting
useful data from Wiki data and we
weren't which is no surprise and uh you
know pretty soon we've got
a person who um
Betsy is born in 1831 he lived to the
age of 49 so 48 so yeah so he was long
dead before his starring role in that uh
movie that he didn't star in but anyway
I mean the what is my point my point is
there is
presumably some somewhat generic anomaly
detection that we could do on data sets
and I don't think we've come back to
think about that since we've had anomaly
detection in machine learning
so let's ask the machine learning this
this might there'll be a function I mean
the the it might be quite useful just to
have a function that actually gives more
directives for what needs to be cleaned
so that you don't have to guess with an
allowingly detector
sure
yes no I know I mean it's a look this
should be asked both of the curation
team and because I think they have tools
like this under the machine learning
team but this this one seems worth worth
talking about
okay yeah
okay array Association
what the heck is this
isn't this Association thread or am I
totally confused
oh no
this is a thing for associatifying an
array
this is very similar to the um uh uh
what are they called the the the the
hardest things that we're building
data container yes data container
I would like this
well this is basically a data container
play
so let's feed this to the data container
where I would use you know a lot where
you import a CSV file and as header rows
but you want to do some manipulating on
the headers before at some point
this is would be really helpful
okay well maybe you should build a wfr
for it and see what see how it works
okay
so Avery please you know make sure it
really has the appropriate information
here but this should definitely come
back when we're talking about data
containers
yep I got it
find character encoding
oh that was a disaster
entry
yeah there's a wfr that has the first
experimental version of this
this was one of those vaunted machine
learning will solve everything type
stories
you see I have to have a little bit of
cynicism in there
is it really that hard I mean this
really we don't have it's not called
that why wouldn't it be called that
huh oh no yeah okay looking back at the
ticket we had talked to Jeremy about
doing that because
they had come up with the initial
version and it apparently never got
pushed out as a wfr so I will follow up
on that okay fine
that's what it should be I mean and
let's see whether it's any good
I don't I doesn't seem to me it should
be so hard and it seems like it will be
useful
okay file partition file drone I thought
we finally had these
I thought so too
um
certainly Constantine I was working on
these at some point yeah there was
recent commenting on a ticket at least
maybe it said okay Avery go chase that
one I don't know what that was there
okay
okay Colonel's available
okay this is a Roman story
um and I don't know whether this is
I mean this should be
I don't quite know what it means
so that's only for parallel kernels if
you launch kernels then kernels will
list there
okay but the fact is okay so look in the
modern kernel management system thing
this becomes more meaningful can we feed
this back to Roman please yep
okay open read write oh my gosh
this is something we talked about I
remember talking to Tom Wickham Jones
about this
and I think it was 1991 or 92.
and we were like and he was like oh yeah
I intend to do that and have open you
know read write streams the fact that
they haven't been needed for 30 years is
probably a sign that we don't shouldn't
do them yeah I mean it's definitely
doable I've I've done it before for very
specific use cases like encrypting a
file in place out of core but it's
dangerous and other than a handful of
very specific use cases I don't know
there are many applications for it yeah
I'd settle for improving our our read
streams and write streams
in what way
uh well one only one of them actually
supports character encodings which is
the right stream
um
and uh
they're probably if that's the main
issue that comes to mind but there are
undoubtedly others that I've encountered
that particular one should be should be
addressed that should be in the queue
seems like this should be hibernated
open read write should probably be
hibernated all right it's been in
hibernation for 30 years it can stay in
hibernation a bit longer
System test
now I we do have a thing in wfr for that
do we not yeah
do people care about it
I haven't seen usage data on that one I
don't know Barbara
not known to me off hand
is it called System test I think there's
a link to it in the on the low hanging
section
oh no okay
they put that in there
I don't remember seeing anything called
System test
doesn't it
um
it's running a standard it's a standard
timing test or am I thinking of the
wrong no that's different that's
benchmarking yeah
you know check if external Services work
check
know very you know you know where this
should be this should be part of the
system Services project
um
because this is exactly that this is a
this is a test of the system Services
actually be a really good thing to have
so you've got your system Services
record and then it's like try test this
yeah I mean make sure I'm connecting to
python appropriately um yeah yeah right
right right I mean that would be super
useful to me you know I've got some
machine I'm going to use it for some
demo it's like does it actually work
yeah it's like oh I don't know you know
you know it has to load you know it has
to you know
set up wire shock or something
who knew yeah probably save Roger
sometime every now and then indeed
indeed
the
uh yes that's that's the right place for
it so
okay range index
what the heck is this
I think this is a supplied story of some
kind yeah
I don't exactly know of what kind maybe
you can unravel what this exactly is but
I think oh oh no no yeah so this is a
little different this was
specifically you know I have a range
that runs from you know 40 to 4 million
what element is this within the range
it's indexing range
well then it's a wfr for now okay
yep
I mean a lot of these wfrs we really
have to try and you know make them more
yeah I mean it's it's still you know I
find myself using some number of wfr
things that are just really useful and
you know but I'm learning only a subset
and maybe that's just the way it's going
to end up being
but
yeah I mean
the which index is it
yeah I mean it's something you
occasionally need
and you know you're always messing
around with off by ones and counting on
fingers and things
um
all right
bitwise functions for byte array okay so
has this actually been done in wfr like
like bit X or of byte arrays
and don't offhand remember that
I don't think it's ever been done right
the stand range is similar but different
say it again there's something called
span range which is similar but not
exactly that
you're talking about bitwise functions
Bob or oh I was talking about range
index range index okay okay
um the uh right and frankly in order for
these to be useful I think they have to
be done in C code anyway right so a
little bit wise functions yeah yes the
bedwise function so I remember I'm not
sure well they should be done with the
compiler this is a good exercise for the
compiler
I mean the the only way to
um do them efficiently avoiding
C code would or the compiler might be
um converting to full words and using
bitwise Ops but there's going to be
efficiency losses there I'm pretty sure
but but the compiler it should work
nicely
don't know I don't have the expertise so
let's let's ask let's ask that question
it might be a trivial thing with the
compiler
it might be so trivial that we could
actually just support you know bit xor
of byte array trivially
right it's not complicated code it's
just a question whether the plumbing
works sufficiently
okay so that's that one okay and I'm
gonna have to go in a moment here but um
synthetic data set
yeah
that is sort of interesting I mean it's
much more wfr like than it is um
um
do you understand what this is right
yeah seems like a machine learning uh
project not a
ild but maybe that's no it's not an ID
project for sure it's a wfr thing that
would be presumably based on machine
learning just try and find the um
you know
I mean certainly I can see this being
useful
although it's kind of hard to Define you
know how close to the original data set
can it be you know if you feed in
Shakespeare do you get out what do you
get out
as a mob right
I was going to say Hemingway but yeah
that's probably better
um
I think that's a that's a nice one I'm
gonna add this to the um uh student
project list yeah
seems like the right kind of place for
it
um
and let me just do that before I forget
uh
[Music]
okay
all right
it's a bit similar to correspondence
sort
has this been wfr or is this proposed to
be wfard
uh the yeah the wfi tag there is a
proposal to wfr sort like is wfr I made
it
what does Salt Lake do it it takes uh a
list and data and it sorts the data like
the list as much as possible
right and it maintains all the data so
you know things that aren't included in
blister
put at the end in the original order
oh I see but it doesn't
I mean if if it sees that
this was intended to be more offensively
heuristic
so yeah this is not fancy at all but
it's practical
seems actually quite useful what you
have there in other words what you're
saying is sort
yeah there's alignment of like rows of
data right
that can be ragged if you have ragged
rows of data
right aligns them I'm going to add this
to the student let's do nothing else I
think we've had it actually before in
the student list
I think it's sort of interesting
um
okay
temporary file block
didn't we do something like this there
was um
with lock but that's different what this
is this is actually interesting and
useful this is something where there's a
block of code it makes the temporary
file and then at the end it cleans it up
mm-hmm yeah I mean I guess we have with
cleanup which sort of makes this trivial
yeah but it's still useful to have the
idea
look this would then
generate a temporary file
temporary file block
you name the temporary file and then it
takes care of creating it and destroying
it
I like this idea
I can certainly
I mean if we can use something like with
cleanup to to do the back end it's
pretty trivial to throw together I think
we touch the Constantine at one point
about it but there wasn't much traction
originally so we'll take another pass
well I guess a real question I mean are
those variables or are those file names
those tmp1 and tmp2
no those are variables
right so variables which are bound to
files
which are just uids in the temporary
directory yeah
and you never have to know what they are
you know that you never see the fact
that it's slash attempt slash blah blah
blah I need to get going here but but um
uh
okay
um
all right this was useful we should go
on with this okay yeah we'll triage what
we've gone through so far and we'll pick
this up another time right yes that's
actually you know this is honestly this
is fairly encouraging I mean this is
this is pretty old stuff and you know
the status of these things is not
horrifying
good
that's reminds me of my 1991 to-do list
which finally got finished years ago
this is only this is only what 10 years
old or something these
um okay good stuff thanks a lot see you
all soon